uh so I grew up in Brooklyn in a small
part of uh by Prospect Park an Irish
Italian neighborhood
um it's Flatbush Kensington where they
all kind of uh come together over there
by the playgrounds in Prospect Park and
um
you know a lot of the guys in the
neighbor everybody was a civil servant
working we went to Catholic school
together and my dad was lieutenant in
homicide in the 13th homicide division
which was you know the worst division in
the city it's 7-3 bedstuy East New York
Brownsville
just like now just a terrible place to
work
and I never really was never my goal to
become a cop I I just my dad didn't
bring his work home was a very bright
man um
when my father was actually lieutenant
in homicide he went back to NYU and got
his Masters
his degree and his master he graduated
to Summer [__] laude which I thought was
tremendous for five children and going
back to school and I never knew that
much about my dad or you know
um you know Irish parents back then uh
not as uh touchy feely as they are now
things were different but I knew my
father did dangerous work um
you know when you went through the
things as we were growing up he was in
Narcotics he worked with a gentleman who
was in his team called Robert Lucy
um I was Prince of the City got into a
big jam and uh
they made a story about him but anyway
as my life goes on I go to Catholic
school I go to Brooklyn Tech and I did
very well I got a uh a little region
scholarship to college and
um just kind of Meandering around and uh
just as
kind of satisfying my parents put my dad
off you know he's what are you doing
what's your future and I was just kind
of going to college to chase the girls
and make some time figure out life you
know so I took the civil service test
um well my buddies from the neighborhood
me Bobby Galvin Timmy Sheridan again all
the Irish kids around we all went to
Catholic School Immaculate Heart of Mary
and on a Saturday
I guess you're about 18 years old with
kids as us and um we all had to take the
test of course would we do we were out
that Friday night before
until six o'clock in the morning you
know a couple cases of beer eight ball
of blow you know doing all the things
you shouldn't be doing
the guy who was running the test uh
Michael Murray uh I think his name was
Michael Tom Michael Murray he was one of
the only cops at that time because back
then there was a big hiring freeze in
the 70s so there wasn't a ton of cops
like they were on Now where you see a
half a dozen 20 10 guys in the
neighborhood on the job or Fire
Department in the 70s things slowed down
and even when I got on a job
a lot of the guys were guys who just got
back from Vietnam or 10 years back and
stuff like that so it was a strange time
um so but Mike Murray was he was a
former Marine he was a buddy of mine
buddy of my older brothers and we get
there and he's like oh look at these you
know Jesus coming through all loaded up
for a little you know fired up straight
from going out all night down the
Rockaway
um
and we all took the test
and you know again pacify our parents
put get them off our back for a while
not a year later because now they're
starting to hire now they're ramping up
and hiring 2500 3 000 cops a class
they're picking us up at 20 years old
we're kids
um and going into you know
um getting uh you're going for your
psych exam your physical but this was
happening I mean like now I don't know
how it happens now but in the old it was
quick every you know they'd go for a
psych go for the physical next thing you
know that they're calling me into
starting the academy
20 years old
I didn't think I you know looking back
you don't think I don't think that's
mature enough to do with this job
especially what I decided to do but
again maybe there's a better way to
manage it but I went on the job I got
out and then went into Coney Island
was my first detail and then um right
into Street narcotics which was in
uniform
it was like the JV of Narcotics kind of
gets you introduced and I was only on
the job a year so for a young man to be
in there
um again the Department's starting to
expand quickly drugs are a mess in 1985
the city is getting them smashed with
crack and everything else so they're
expanding quickly
as soon as I'm in there I spend a year
in there and I
applied becoming undercover cop but in
other words there's a different
everybody says Undercover on the cover
there's all kinds of Undercovers uh I
was buying I was strictly buying
narcotics and you do that for that's the
fast track because no one wants to do it
it's very dangerous to get your gold
shield
usually takes three years at least and
back then that wasn't even a guarantee
but if you did 18 months buying and you
were successful they'd promote you so I
go in and I look like I'm I look like
I'm 18 years old I mean I look like a
kid and
in the beginning it wasn't bad because
you know you have a fresh face you're
going out there
and and normally and when you're going
into these rough neighborhoods and when
you're narcotics there are no good
neighbors you're working in but you're
going into these rough neighborhoods and
you're coming over the border from a
white neighborhood and they either see
you you're either a cop or a drug addict
you know what I mean so they know what
you're coming there for you're not
walking through the projects
just because you're an average Joe I'm
going to work or going home you're going
around the projects if you're regular
going to work you know just staying away
from that but if you're going through
when people and by the way
the drug dealers had a little bit of a
policy you know don't [__] without what
he call our clients
you know in other words if you're a bad
guy and you're robbing people well don't
be robbing my clients because they're
not going to lose business so that they
would just let you let you come and go
and everybody was good so uh it's a very
strange uh Dynamic the way that works I
I tell people
you know the whole
uh drug uh industry and
that goes with this is very you know I
worked in one uh Spanish neighborhood
and he ate three and it was it was
I mean polluted with Heroin at the time
and um saw Street I remember there was a
woman who got killed over there
Hernandez I got shot through the window
and they made a real big oh forget about
the you know enforcement over there but
my point being they would not sell drugs
from eight o'clock in the morning till
nine and from 2 30 to 3 30 or 2 30 or
three to four when the kids were going
to school and coming home that was there
they had this mental thing that they
weren't bad guys because they weren't
selling drugs when kids were coming and
going to school
it was bizarre and then you would see
the junkies Milling around you know that
when they started dealing again at four
o'clock you'd see there'd almost be a
line of guys waiting
and um
as I got more and more uh you know
started buying more and more
people they're shop guys some of these
guys some a lot of the dealers are just
dealing enough to get there to get high
but there's the guys who are out there
making the money there's one guy who
knows what he's doing well there's
different degrees
and they start recognizing every time
you pop up those guys are getting caught
so they may put two and two together
so we used to do different things and
that I thought of I said look
don't call these guys right after I do
it they're called Blind bust
let them stay out there we'll come let
me buy this place let's go to another
set we'll come back
get them in an hour or two they're not
going home for the night they don't work
one hour a day and that seemed to work
for a while
but then it got they didn't they started
a new program called TNT and they were
just flooding the streets with uh you
know buying bust they and I mean teen
they went from in our building 300
um uh detect on you know uh narcotics
guys to a thousand and they were just
bombarding them all day all night with
just buying a bus so they were getting
raised up
and they wouldn't do white guys uh if
you spoke Spanish if you're black got a
lot easier going
then you had to just figure out
different ways to get done you know you
go up there you had an old name you had
to know speak a little Spanish you had I
used to wear different outfits uh
sanitation man uniform I would say you
know they had they would ask if you had
works on you again they were getting a
little sharper because they were getting
hurt hot you know hit so hard
but
my boss loved me because I had balls I
didn't I did not care
I had no respect for them I had no
respect for money I just didn't I wasn't
afraid of it some people couldn't get
over that fear and they used to ask me
and I was like you got to go up there
like this is you have a junkie you
better believe in your heart that you're
a junkie so I used to go up there and
they'd be like
hey officer you know my hair was down in
my back and on my shoulders
um sometimes I'd walk up with just a
pair of shorts and flip-flops on no no
shirt no nothing I was 170 pounds I'd
walk up
they'd be like oh the hey officer the
preaching's down the block I go listen
[__] I don't get served no one's
getting served I'm first in line I don't
give a [__] who's waiting here you're
serving me or no one's getting served so
my boss always make the joke
wasn't good about Quinlan
we're either going to get some a sale or
somebody for assault Because by the time
it's over it's gonna beat the [__] out
of somebody so there were some you know
scuffles but that was the way to do it
you had to go up there and say
listen man we can hide together you know
what I would do anything I'd pick up
hookers on the way there throw them in
the car we I would stop
um one other famous thing if you'd
worked up in uh I mean Upper West Side
all the guys from Georgia would come
over the bridge with their Jersey plates
and the guys they didn't get what they
knew you were coming to buy drugs they
buy quantity because they take it back
with them a lot of times they buy say a
hundred caps you know of crack or 10 10
bundles of heroin a bundle is 10 bags
I always tell everybody 10 bags 10 glass
scenes of heroin is this has been the
same price forever I beg I have one was
ten dollars it's been ten dollars since
1920. it's ten dollars now it's never
going to change or anybody tells you
different
they don't know narcotics and so a
bundle of 10 bags usually get seven if
you buy a bundle you get it for 70 bucks
they give you a little discount
so again getting back to Jersey guys
they drive over the bridge and we'd wait
in the corner for them to pick up their
stuff
pull them over
now your car is my car with the Jersey
plates I'm driving around again totally
illegal I'm driving around the Upper
West Side
with their car with Jersey license
plates and they're they're running
they're flocking to your car it was so
polluted with drugs up there it was uh
like you've never seen in your life I
mean whole blocks would just be
inundated with you know you you'd buy
you could buy from three different guys
on the same block at the same time you
buy crack don't pot pills some blocks I
remember 170th and Broadway was just a
nightmare
one night before I got into narcotics
two cops were killed up there uh Hoban
and I forget the other gentleman's name
what was an undercover cop and one was
doing an arresting chasing the guy for
and you're both killed and that's when
it said he went [__] Bonkers we're
gonna shut this [__] down this ain't go
this was back in the day when
men were men they weren't [__]
playing games and uh they started
getting rough and shutting shut down and
everything moved inside
and that's hairy when you're buying
inside
you know
you walk into a place and
it's a
you know I never realized this okay I
remember I spent my entire career doing
this I didn't go you only supposed to
spend three years in Narcotics I spent
15.
and I never realized how much this is
affecting me because it became my entire
life that's it that's all I I never
thought I never really worked on patrol
doing this other [__] that other cops do
that's all I knew and when you're doing
this when you work in iconics you're out
three nights a week at least doing
enforcement I mean you're wrestling with
these [__] guys doing you know
arresting people and these aren't
gentlemen they don't so you put your
hands behind your back you know rock and
roll and uh a lot of these guys just
scattered a joint they're in good shape
but the funny thing was the guys who've
been arrested before they got it they
saw us and we had guys in our team who
everybody was in shape big guys a lot of
they said they look like the um ivy
league linebackers some of the guys were
doing the arrests I was doing the buys
and they weren't taking [__] I mean you
couldn't and you know I that's what
happened uh if anything stuck with me in
my life
I I have an issue with someone gets in
my face
even now even if it's just
you know just that me and you it's you
meet someone on the bus and they're
having a rough day and it happens but
they you know [__] what the [__] you
doing right away I'm like looking to go
because in those days if you didn't
they'd walk all over you they would just
stop you into the ground they see
weakness like the jungle and I never
thought of that my whole life until the
last few years and I said
you know I got to take a step back and
say I'm not a kid anymore and I can't
fight everybody I've been arrested three
times since I retired in two years for
fighting and I wouldn't take please
because I said
um I didn't do anything wrong but defend
myself but at the end of the day
you start thinking
I could have walked away from that I
could have just said you're beginning
I'm leaving but I'm not that's just not
your way when you do when you learn this
in your life that you you're the one who
makes the rules at least I say that to
guys
this is your this might be you you know
what you do this is our [__] house
we're making the rules here man and the
strange thing was because we we didn't
use like old police the old mock cars
you know unmarked cars that you would
see they look like police cars you could
tell them a block away
first of all we've taken people's cars
away from them and using that cause and
then
we would
the ones we liked we would confiscate
them and keep them and sign them over to
us because you're not allowed to use
your car to buy narcotics
but the other thing was they got smart
and they started leasing cars and they
were all you know Hondas and Toyotas and
cars that cops did not drive
and um
so that for a long time that was working
really well I mean they were they were
getting sophisticated and doing things
um that just you know um were changing
as they change because again they got a
little more sophisticated knowing who we
were you know they had balls too they'd
come they found out where our office was
we didn't we weren't in a Precinct we
were in like a little office building in
the middle of Bay Ridge
and um they would send guys down and
take photos of the all the Leicester
plates on the cars in the middle of the
night these guys had balls you know they
didn't [__] their animals and they
probably sent some kid or whatever you
can see bikes going around but you know
um again back then we caught somebody
out there taking pictures
and beat the [__] out of him I mean beat
the [__] out of him and again this is
you rationalize this in your head as
I'm doing I'm taking I'm protecting my
team and I'm protecting the neighborhood
because these are bad guys
so there was always a sense that
um
you know in your head
I'm only doing
to guys that are in this game in other
words they're going to hurt me and they
do and they heard Lots I mean you gotta
see a lot of cops getting be hurt and
beat up and stabbed and shot
um especially narcotics and a lot of it
doesn't go out because they're trying to
protect the uh the name of narcotics
officers and their identity and stuff
but
um
in your head you're going
I only did it Heming he's a scumbag he's
been arrested 20 times a piece of
garbage [__] him you know he's in the
game he knows this is part of the game
so you this is how you're saying to
yourself how this is how you get through
this and say
I'm actually doing a good thing I'd
never do this to the librarian or the
doctor or the nurse or the you know the
I mean the regular people regular we
call them civilians
they would never get because we'd never
have contact with them
but if you're a bad guy
then the rules are out the window and um
that's the way it goes and they
understood the rules there was just
rules of the street if you got caught
with a gun
beaten you're getting a beaten if you
look and I didn't mean that that was
just the way it was because you're going
to use that gun on someone either a cop
or someone else to hurt him if you ran
from the cops when they caught you and
they did beaten don't run again next
time you won't run so there was just a
real
um laws of the land that had to do with
this stuff
accepted by the bad guys as well as the
good guys you know everybody understood
it you didn't
draw outside those lines and anything
you did
and that the longer you stayed in the
more you started bending the rules and
playing outside the rules you know you
know what
this guy's got 20 grand on what the [__]
is that like two grand for myself
uh No One's Gonna what the [__] they're
just gonna take the money and what they
do is they mark it and incinerate it
that it's called they put an Evidence
stamp on it it's gone but if you put a
ticket before it goes no one sees the
difference it's it's it's uh ghost money
I call it ghost money
because no one knows about that money
it's not no one got a paycheck for it
it's no one wasn't given to you and you
spent it and took it out of a bank
account it's all Drug Money so the more
you did that the more you said again I
just doesn't happen immediately but
little by little things start creeping
up you start getting worse and you now
you're in my in my case I can only speak
myself because there are plenty of guys
who didn't do these things and and again
I don't blame nobody but myself you know
for the things that I've done
but I didn't I did them within the you
know of the life of working in Narcotics
or being around these people and
you start living a life of um
a double life so I'm I'm going out with
girls I'm married full-fledged marriage
house everything I'm I'm going out with
other women
and not just go like just you know going
fooling around with them and stuff going
to weddings with girls and go on
vacations
at one time one time I stole some uh
some um what do you calls to subpoenas I
would send them to my house that I had
to testify and you know in the Bahamas
and I want some broad going on vacation
and
it was just and again I don't know why
in my life I didn't see
um that this is wrong but again I'm
justifying by saying I've got to do this
because this is part of this whole thing
and I'd be bouncing around with
strippers and this girl and not just me
that was again you grab you gravitate
towards other guys who are living the
same life as you the streets become part
of you yes for sure
but you can I mean the funny thing is
you go home and you live like your old
self
but when you when you're there or when
you're out with the boys you're living
like a gangster you know so to speak in
this little world of
different names safe houses safe
Apartments stealing manipulating people
um and you're saying but you know what
at the end of the day I'm helping put
bad guys away
and I'm not hurting any good people
that's how you rationalize it at you
know that you can continue to do this
and to me
you know I had I knew guys who were
drunks and addicts and whatever that
wasn't my bag I wasn't um I'm not a guy
I drank every day what I did do come
payday every two weeks I like to rock
and roll I was an action guy so I get
paid
just like knew nothing to pay at three
o'clock I'm already getting butterflies
I'm like wow like three o'clock
hit the Bars by six o'clock we'll have
an eight ball split up drinking
now we're chasing girls and I'm lucky if
I showed up some strange bed by Sunday
back to work on Monday you know but
again this was all in the you know in
the pursuit of information
and um getting out there with people
going no that guy can't be a comment you
know because that was my thing
if any of the guys will because I
started buying more and more wheat and
that's what I was at the end what I was
specifically doing you know I wouldn't
even I wouldn't even touch nothing less
than eight ball they would give me an
eight ball to taste and um
so you'd have to play that game yeah
he's a crooked cop or whatever everybody
knows he's good he's one of the boys you
know whatever and so you start lip
feeding into that and um you know you
get involved you know when you're in
Narcotics
all the other [__]
uh the illegal [__] that comes with it
whether it's strippers and you're not
that not that's illegal but you know
they have their own thing going on and
those little games that they play and
then there's you know even the stolen
cars it's just everything around it is
bad money Dirty Money dirty guys dirty
business
and again it's all relative to and it
comes back to the one thing money and
narcotics and uh
so you you me I don't want to say about
other people I can only control for
myself I convinced myself
at the end of the day I'm doing good I'm
doing good because I'm putting bad guys
away I'm then and I'm not hurting any
good guys but the line between what's
right and wrong gets blurred very much
so there is no line it became if it came
to a place there was no more line there
was no more line I was living a life of
you know when I went home I lived my
life as James Quinlan and when I was at
work I had Charles
whatever my name was and your marriage
fair I lost my first marriage and um
you know the nicest girl beautiful my
high school sweetheart I love her she's
a great kid we're still friends thank
god
um but yeah destroyed that marriage
um
and
you know it's a certain good degree I
just didn't even see that you know
because
honestly I didn't really care I had no
um
uh maybe self-awareness suffers I didn't
think I'd lived that long I really
didn't think I'd lived past 40 or like
that and didn't care is there something
addictive about that danger yes
and that's it at the very end what
happened was
um I went to leave narcotics and go
become a teacher in Narcotics we'll take
a hater and um when you do that
I'm going into this this
uh where people come in to learn about
narcotics and people give them their
experience and who more would have more
than me after 15 years was Undercover I
did this for three weeks one day I went
out for lunch
drove straight to One PP and retired and
they said
the boss is coming away I said I quit
and I would tell you what if I told him
I said no I'm out I don't want to do
[__] anymore
he goes and I don't it's easy easy let's
talk let me have people trying to talk
messages I don't want to do this anymore
if there wasn't I'm not hard feelings I
just couldn't be cooped up in an office
all day I'm stay on the clock
you know for 15 years was there a draw
to go back to the dangerous life I could
have went back there but I was it was
getting um hairy for me there was
getting close calls
um and I knew that too that that would
end badly and the best escape for me was
to go start fresh
get away from it start fresh and even
when I did leave
for a while I didn't even contact the
guys my old friends in the police
department I kind of just went and tried
to get myself to do something different
but it was like you said I just for me
to sit in an office all day we we used
to buy money to go in bars and go you
know go to go to the bar I heard there's
someone supposedly there's someone below
just about doing you're going there part
of your jobs have drinks with girls and
drink and they're paying for it and
spend the night now that's your job
you know then now you want me to sit in
the office and [__] debate because
you can justify the fun lifestyle oh
yeah it was part of it and again the
other thing was
because who we were nobody
nobody wants to do this [__] I mean
nobody has I don't want to say the
courage but they know how hairy this is
this could be really really hairy stuff
it really I'm not telling you how you
know very dangerous stuff every day or
three four times a week at best at worst
and um
so nobody really wants to do it so they
kind of
don't want it they don't want to know
all the all the stuff that's going on as
long as the job is getting done to some
degree
and like we would call her up say and um
you'd do like a one to nine say uh one
you have to do until night at night you
take five hours overtime
everybody will get five hours
and that brings it to two in the morning
everybody told me that bad by midnight
one guy would stay till the next day
and we got off at two o'clock in the
morning
you'd sign right back on
and start your next tour so basically
you went from one to like nine o'clock
the next day you did two days and you
would do that on a Thursday and that
Saturday Friday Saturday Sunday Monday
off whatever so
again now you want me to go sit in an
office or I'm really only working three
days a week when I'm not working I'm not
at the office I'm just everybody's got
that uh uh what do you call
beepers on and then it became phones
well you could if you needed me and the
bosses were in there I mean everybody
was it was a way of life uh Jimbo if
you're going to be running around keep
your phone on you know that was the one
thing because you don't want to [__] the
duck and everybody's in trouble and that
happened finally at the end
um they got jammed up signing people in
and out and they consider that theft of
services and one guy killed himself over
it it was messy
um really got really really messy
someone must have dropped a dime and
said it was really um and it wasn't just
all roughers every narcotics office did
it and they kind of did it
in my opinion yeah we know they're doing
it but these guys are [__] doing
dangerous [__] so who cares let them do
that thing they're doing work that
nobody else wants to do what are they
gonna do anyway sit at their desk and
stare at the walls reminds me home in
bed catching goodness this way when
they're out doing their thing
everything's
um safe and we're not having those kind
of problems so again it just seems like
it was chaotic
but everybody in there was
there were very few women in there uh
and the women that were in there
couldn't stay on the street but more
than a few months and then
um they'd be in the office doing some
[__] work because
they were liability I I don't want to
say that like a chauvinist but the truth
is you know they're not wrestling with
six foot two 240 pound guys they're
getting flung around and getting you
away and making things worse
and I got to give it to them they at
least they understood that and said I'll
take a job you know making up the
schedules and the bosses were some
overtime so everybody it was kind of a
wink wink listen you still get paid
you're gonna get your Shield but just
get out of my way is there any
withdrawal for you getting out
no
um not two years not till like five
years ago I had it was an odd thing
um
I never had I never I don't know why it
just didn't come to me but about five
years ago
um someone started talking about a show
called The Wire which I never seen
um and I put it on because you know I
just want to say this time I was in the
film industry I was working on Ray
Donovan uh
uh I ran the security for the show and
um I put it on and had to do a what they
call ghosting so if you're gonna go out
and buy for make a buy we tell you the
locations 47 the Broadway I'm your ghost
I follow a half a block behind you but
you're always in my sight to make sure
you're okay the [__] hits the fan I jump
you know what I mean I call for help but
I jump in
and that's how we do it's called
ghosting it's very difficult to do that
without raising up the set they call it
without making people aware that there's
two cops popping around one guy's here
who's that other guy just lingering
around you know so you you have to do
that in a way that you don't look you
know
and I thought that was a very
um
you know maybe the most difficult thing
to do in Narcotics to act like you you
belong there when you don't and so
people don't recognize at the set that
you're on the set trying to protect your
friend and make the whole thing blow up
so I'm watching to show The Wire
and one of those whoever did that show
was in this business was for sure in his
business because he got it it's a hair
it's that feeling you get before you
step out of the car you know you're
gonna go by
and you go and you know this is one
spot's worse than the other you go
sometimes you're going through the
projects you're walking up three flights
of stairs
there's no elevators working now you're
in the stairwells every Savage was in
the [__] stairwells it's stinks like
piss they're getting high you got to
walk past these guys to go up and go
into the apartment the door gets locked
it's just so you get butterflies and I
remember watching a show about the about
The Ghost and he was having reservations
because he goes how the [__] am I going
to go this guy when he goes to the
projects how far can I let him get ahead
of me until I lose sight of him now he's
your responsibility and they say they
don't they [__] and say they'd
rather than make the buy as long as he's
safe
they want you making those Buys so
when he was saying that I said it really
struck me I was like wow that feeling
just came back that feeling of
butterflies of how dangerous this could
be and you try to just put it out of
your mind and
um we did one buying the projects one
time and I bought the guy and the boss
says to me make sure you buy this
[__] guy inside we want to take your
palm it's like okay so I go in and buy
him he's with his girl
and she's sitting there on him whatever
getting high doing that thing and then
we go back to he goes back to hit the
door
and uh
they're not going to do it he goes um
who's there
now again it's my boy Stevie Richardson
big guy tough [__]
he goes uh
it's uh it's a gas company
get the [__] out of here
he waits about 15 minutes
knocking the door
who is it it's a super I got the gas
company with me
get the [__] out of here I'll blow your
[__] head off
10 minutes later
knocks on the door
listen to me if you don't get the [__]
out of here I'm calling 5-0 with this
they knocked the [__] door down with
the [__] battery Ram he's under the
door naked he goes I am five oh
[__] and this guy's buried under
the door naked but he went back three
times knocking on the door like I said
he wouldn't give up
I said Steve why didn't we just go back
yesterday and get a circle [__] him he's
not pulling that [__] on me so there's a
certain enough I'm proud going back and
forth it was just so funny some of this
[__] that happened just uh and that's
why I think there's a lot of police
stories you just can't make them up I
mean it's so [__] crazy out there you
cannot make up some of the [__] that
goes on it's uh do you miss it I do I
missed the camaraderie of it uh I really
do
um I know it's changed so much that you
couldn't do the things yeah I'll tell
you another thing that just
to this day I don't know if this is
right or wrong
suppose we lock you up and you're a real
junkie heroinatican there is a real
withdrawals that comfortable if you
don't get sickness um physical
withdrawals you'll get sick
so we'd have that problem we locked up
some guys they'd be waiting at the cop
or they just got there so they didn't
get a chance to get high or get straight
they close because now they're just you
know
and now they're at the precinct getting
processed and now it's going to be two
or three days until they get to back out
and they're getting sick
so what happens now one of the
conferences got to take them to the
hospital and babysit them until they're
ready to go to court and they get their
methadone
that sucks it's just two days you're
sitting there with this guy handcuffs
and saying my boss would go
listen to me take him into the bathroom
and let them clean up and on the side of
the bathroom he'd leave three bags of
dope on the side of the sink
and he goes and the guys would go and
get high and be good for the next two
two days
a couple times guys don't see the [__]
he's like a [__] I told you I'll
clean the [__] up because I did boss I
did go clean up again and look around by
the sink please make sure it's all clean
clean yourself in the sink
that goes back ah I get you boy shut the
[__] up you know it was just it's hard
to imagine the dark humor that went on
there and you're saying yourself oh God
what I mean then you say come up with
that game this [__] this [__]
has a OD he's out in front of me I mean
you know you don't know what you're
doing and you're trying to do all these
things and juggle all these things that
are really really
if not
wrong or definitely you know in a gray
area for sure
but you know you you the real it's a
real these are survival instincts
instincts because
I I cannot describe to you like in bed
style and how hairy it really is out
there you could just you go out there
especially the white guy in a very rough
neighbor like that you can feel how you
know difficult this is how dangerous
this is and even after years that that
feeling does not go when you're in that
car ready to go out to you go out and
you you test the Kells which is the you
know the transmitter
and you're about to step out if you
don't get that butterfly feeling then
you're in trouble because you become an
adrenaline junkie yeah and if you don't
get that feeling then you're in trouble
because now you you don't understand the
severity and the danger that's going on
here you've You've Lost Your wretch you
know
and then when you and I was graduating
buying kilos half you know half a kilo
half gun two guns and a kilo here
um counterfeit money everything
everything that was um that you could
discuss with
um
one night we have a guy we would take
him out to a strip joint so we have and
this is an expensive place
and we have
different tops in different places at
different tables you know uh sitting
around to make sure everything's okay
and my boss is there and I'm ordering
bottles of champagne at three 400 a
bottle I dropped a couple thousand
dollars in there flinging money around
and he's [__] and as I'm passing by
he's giving me the [__] death eye you
know he's [__] pissed I'm dropping
this you know it's not his [__] money
so I don't know anyway I said um
I guess your back goes on a big shot
he spent like five grand I go how about
we do a different thing
why don't you go out and hang out with
these [__] Savages and you can start
putting dollar bills out when they're
spending 20s because in five [__]
minutes they're gonna know you're full
of [__] that you're not a real [__]
drug guy you're not a you're not a real
dealer when you're dropping one singles
and he's [__] dropping 20s and 50s on
these [__] strippers I said so if
you're better at this why don't you do
it [__] I don't see you stepping
up to do it I don't got the look I said
I'll get you to look don't worry just
give me a month you'll look don't worry
about it it ain't the look it's the
attitude and someone must have told me
because ah you're right I said what do
you give a [__] it's none of your money
it's the money we take from these [__]
we you know you regenerate that money it
goes around the circle and they just put
it out
you're right you're right now you know I
got to talk to you guys sometimes I said
okay at least he said you know there
came something of it like
I only see the paperwork I'm the
lieutenant so I see the paperwork and I
only get my balls busted when I ask for
another twenty thousand dollars and uh
buying money or spending whatever you
want to call it that they use
and that was another thing I would do
because I was a white guy
you know these guys will go by you know
give me full glass things four bags you
know nope I go
give me 30 30 caps 30. what crackheads
buying 30 at once I don't know I sell
them to my other guys and they were
white boy prices right you charge me
five I charged them ten they're like oh
you know the green so I had all these
things figured out you know all these
[__] ways to do things my boss was
like what the [__] is wrong with you I
hear you out there then you're picking
fights with people I go what are you
talking about
that's I go look you think everybody out
there is a drug addict you think they're
giving hugs and kisses they're looking
to Rob they're [__] stealing from
each other and manipulating each other
you know I says and he goes and they're
picking up the hook is to bring them
with your on drug deals I go yeah it
gives me a little cuff like you know the
drug dealers hang out with hookers it's
all one big [__] happy family and so
he finally got wind of it he was a guy a
great guy but never was involved in this
industry and all the [__] comes together
in this industry
and the you know it was a sad thing I
was thinking I was what to talk to you
about and and part of it was you know
you'd see somebody let's say some girl
who's a beautiful girl and she got
caught up in stripping or whatever the
[__] case her boyfriend's an [__]
and turned her around and you met her
when she just thought of this stuff a
couple months in then you see her two
years later
and she looks unrecognizable she looks
like [__] that the world just crushed
her because she's been using crack and
getting abused for two years as it said
it's a sad sad story uh and it's going
to continue there's so much money in it
right now it's just um
uh it's unbelievable and so I I at the
end at the end
and they got this stuff out there now my
understanding is you know the fentanyl
it's just taking over
they can't control it but they're not
gonna because the demand is so high you
know and until they understand that I
don't know that this will ever get uh
changed uh for that being so immersed in
the the snake pit like this for so many
years what have you learned about human
nature about life about people
you know what I've and it's sad I I'm
well at the end I I so many people you
dealt with in this business all they do
is lie and manipulate you know about
because they don't they have no they
have no conscience no nothing they'll do
anything for a nickel for drugs and and
I the other thing is that drugs
take people's lives over completely I
mean completely and I tell people
I can't tell you the amount of families
I've seen to destroy you know if you've
got a child and
you say your daughter she's a beautiful
girl but she gets hooked
I go to you
she'll find the weakest link in your
family whether it's your mother her
grandmother her your brother her uncle
her cousin whoever she can manipulate
for twenty dollars a day to get high
that will be her person and then but
they don't tell you about that you you
haven't slept in six months because
you're worried every night that your
daughter's out there she disappears for
two or three days at a time you don't
know if she's overdosed
um she gets arrested here and there she
gets raped again these things are just
these are this is not make believe it's
it's
tragic and it destroys the innocent
people it destroys families and not just
the person who's who's the addict it
destroys their entire family
and I'll tell you the one other thing
that I know 30 days is not enough for a
person to go to rehab
you don't go to rehab for every bit
every bit of a year and then when that's
over you cannot go back to where you
came from it's people and places if you
go back to people the neighborhood you
came from your old friends
30 days you'll relapse because it's just
there it's part of your life and you
always come back you know
um I know guys now who are destroyed
with this um
at the opioid crisis
um I guess I've John my friend John
Ailey lost his daughter the last few
months another gentleman that I work
with Reed is his son uh his brother died
my nephew was a grad he got a full ride
to Penn University
overdosed
um my the veterinarian my brilliant guy
his son is in Columbia veterinarian
school Cornell
comes home one weekend takes a couple
pills that were laced with fentanyl dyes
this is in the last two years
and um epidemic people like I've never
seen because
again when I was unstarted in 1985 or
all the time I was in iconics Harry was
considered a dirty business
it wasn't it wasn't so um prolific with
everybody you know when I was in high
schools it's all over the place it's
really gotten it's it's Hooks and
everybody in every part of society
um there's no innocent people out there
and I I don't know what the answer is I
mean these doctors are prescribed these
opioids and once what happens with those
is once you can't afford those enough
you go from spending thirty dollars on a
pill
to now ten dollars on a bag of dope and
the same thing that one blue pill that
30 milligram or Oxycontin is equivalent
to one glassine of dope well when you
can't afford the 30 ounce I might as get
a bag of dope for ten and I can get
three of those instead of one
so
um I don't know what the answer is to
any of this stuff and then
I do know it's sad you know uh and it's
and again destroying our country from
the inside out and it's a mess it's a
mess and uh
boy oh boy the problem is and I think
you'll agree my brother always says if
if you want to know what where the uh
where the problem starts just follow the
money and the truth is there's so much
money in this stuff when these guys get
pinched for
you know two million pills of opioids or
you know
factually we only get 10 of the drugs
that come in this country it's a fact
so for that two million got in
200 million got away or whatever 20
million got away at least I mean so I
don't it's going to come from education
or something but uh right now it's it's
really destroying our country from the
inside out and so
um
I I don't know in my life I've learned
that you know those things that I
thought weren't so bad that I was doing
um I realized they are bad you know I
just can't rationalize because I decided
to do something you know it hurt my
relationships with friends and my wife
because I was again
um
trying to make excuses for things that I
knew my heart were wrong you know and I
knew better my father it was funny I'll
never forget my father said when I first
started job don't go into narcotics it's
a dirty business
30 business and it is and that's the
reason they don't want you being in
there more than a couple years because
it'll just get into your blood and I
just stayed and no one forced me out
someone should have sat me down and said
this has taken over you've done too much
you know you've been here too long you
should have gotta you should go do
something else that you're interested in
matter of fact I should have said what
do you want to do you like what do you
want as a reward we've done five years
ten years you want to go to Intel you
want to go to autocrime what do you want
to do
and that's the way they should but no
one said anything as long as you're
doing their thing and the moment you
retire you're out you're finished
and there's another guy steps up so
all right Jim thank you so much for
sharing your story my pleasure
interesting as can be
thank you